Ever superhero needs a supervillain, but when
it comes to the comic book industry, one rivalry
rises above all others: Marvel vs DC Comics.
Long before the companies dreamed of shared
movie universes, fans debated which heroes
would come out on top: Marvel’s Avengers,
or DC’s Justice League.
The fans aren’t always going to agree, and
the heroes definitely won’t be doing battle
any time soon.
So for now, we can only look to the comics
and imagine how a battle between Marvel and
DC’s best and brightest would play out.
Mare sure you let us know hwat you think in
the comments below!
Here is our answer to the question – The
Avengers vs. Justice League: Who Would Win?
Captain America vs. Batman
It’s only fair to give each superhero a
single opponent, and it’s hard to think
of two men less alike than Steve Rogers and
Bruce Wayne.
Embodying the brightest and darkest of humanity,
these two would let their martial arts training
do the talking.
Cap would have an edge thanks to his superhuman
strength, but Batman has never needed a superpower
beyond his gadgets, intellect, and gift for
planning ahead.
Both men would land some punches, but considering
Batman is the only person trusted to bring
down Superman, and is willing to cross lines
no good soldier ever would, there’s no way
Cap comes out ahead.
Wonder Woman vs. Thor
It wouldn’t be a battle between good and
evil, but a fight between god and goddess
would be one for the ages.
Both are divine juggernauts in their own universe,
but most of the Asgardians and Amazons superpowers
would be cancelled out, since both are almost
completely invincible.
But even if Diana’s powers come from the
ancient Greek gods, Thor’s are completely
alien and cosmic in origin.
Add in his ability to fly into Warrior’s
Madness, granting him nearly limitless strength
and rage, and even Diana’s divine magic
would be tested.
She may have been noble enough to wield Thor’s
hammer in the comics, but in a head-to-head
fight, there’s just no matching the god
of thunder.
Iron Man vs. Cyborg
It’s hard to know which would be the more
important angle of this battle: robotic suits,
or IQs.
Tony Stark and Vic Stone were both brilliant
men before tragedy struck, merging their bodies
with cutting-edge technology (in Cyborg’s
case, literally replacing his lost limbs and
organs with advanced tech).
There’s no question Cyborg would land some
punishing hits, particularly with his sonic
cannon, but he became a DC icon based on his
personality – not lethality.
The fight would prove that Cyborg deserves
just as much fame as Iron Man, but in the
end, Tony’s knack for invention and global
protection would give him the upper hand,
even if he needed to create a brand new weapon
or government agency to do it.
Superman vs. Hulk
It may not be the marquee match-up comic fans
would hope for, but if it’s Superman’s
job to take on the biggest physical threat,
then Hulk is his man.
The two have both been given almost endless
power over the years, with Hulk able to survive
nuclear bombs, and apparently not given any
limit to how strong his anger can make him.
Unfortunately for him, Superman is Superman.
Without Kryptonite or magic, there’s almost
no blow Superman couldn’t survive.
Plus, you don’t need to destroy Hulk to
beat him, since a quick trip to the Moon would
take him out of the fight.
And if there’s one League member who you
just can’t stay mad at, it has to be the
mild mannered Kansas farm boy.
Green Lantern vs. Captain Marvel
As a pair of fighter pilots who cross paths
with alien warriors and wind up superheroes
patrolling deep space, Hal Joran and Carol
Danvers would have plenty to talk about.
Ms. Marvel’s gifts are a result of fusing
with the alien DNA of the original Captain
Marvel, meaning she can fly, survive in space,
and even fire powerful energy blasts from
her hands.
But the Green Lantern ring is something of
a “win” button in this fight, since Hal
could create almost anything he could imagine
– including replicating Carol’s own powers.
Even without the Corps at his back, Hal has
found a way to win almost every fight the
DC universe could throw at him.
With his ring in hand, Ms. Marvel would learn
the hard way that the Lantern’s oath is
also a warning to any would-be challengers.
Aquaman vs Namor The Submariner
For the sake of Marvel AND DC fans, it’s
best not to point out all the similarities
between their half human/half-Atlantean warriors.
They’re basically identical, with both heroes
able to live underwater, and being able to
communicate and work with marine life – when
they’re not too busy leading their kingdoms.
Namor’s strange or unexplained powers would
be the biggest difference, since he can fly
thanks to wings growing out of his ankles,
and control water itself.
Fans might hope that the two sons of the ocean
and mainland could find common ground, but
given both of their tempers, a fight is inevitable.
And even if it’s due to his extra mutant
powers, the Sub-Mariner has the advantage.
Spider-Man vs. The Flash
How do you stop a hero able to move at the
speed of light?
Easy, put him up against a man who can sense
the future.
Peter Parker’s spidey sense would help him
evade some of The Flash’s attacks, and he’s
got the brains to keep a trick or two up his
sleeve… but DC has made it clear that Barry
Allen and Wally West are almost impossible
to stop once their full power is unlocked.
The Flash would win this round, but honestly,
the two jokesters are just as likely to become
best friends before a punch is even thrown.
If we tally everything up, it seems Justice
League would take it home… but that’s
just one way we see a showdown between Marvel
and DC’s greatest heroes shaking out, but
what do you think?
Were our predictions in line with your own,
or do you think we’re selling some of the
heroes short?
Share your own picks in our comment section
and don't forget to subscribe to our channel
to watch more great videos like this one!